- That's pretty bad ass,
though, that what he did.
I would high five my
grandpa if he did that.
If I didn't see him for a
long time and he's like,
"Yo, I tricked you (bleep)."
- I love Christmas.
- I hate, like, when Christmas
music starts playing.
- I travel back home and spend time
with my family during the holidays.
- Talking about what you
did throughout the year.
Talking about what you didn't do
and how you're a failure.
- I usually spend it with my family,
but not this year.
- Is this gonna make me cry?
- Okay, so his daughter just called.
She said they're not
coming home for Christmas.
- Lonely grandpa, oh no.
- That's very sad.
- Oh no, a picture of gramps.
- Oh no, he died!
- [Voiceover] Did he trick
his family that he died?
- What the (bleep)?
- What a clever old man.
- Surprise!
- Dude.
- This would've been a good,
like yeah, Skype commercial.
- That was an emotional
rollercoaster, for sure.
- I feel, I feel like
you can make heartwarming
Christmas commercials without
faking someone's death.
- I wasn't ready for that feels trip.
- Why couldn't they just fly him to them?
- Like maybe have a like real
conversation with your kids.
You know, maybe don't be just like,
"Ah, I guess I'll just fake my own death."
- He had a right to trick them because
they were being shitty kids.
- And look how happy that family was,
like at the end of the commercial.
- I'd be so pissed.
- This is the girl that
hates Christmas music.
- They have a family, what
the (bleep) is his problem?
- I don't know what his problem is, right?
He must be, oh my god, do you think--
- I didn't want to say it.
- I just think about that moment
where all the ad execs
were sitting in a room
going, "Oh, I know."
- I kinda want to call
my grandpa right now.
- I don't have the time
and the money to get there
and now I feel guilty.
I feel like I should make the time.
- I do want to spend time with my family
after watching it, but it's just--
- At what cost.
- He's lucky he didn't get shot.
He's lucky one of the kids didn't see him
and be like ghost!
(pow)